[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم وافقت بلديه القدس على مخطط
لبناء نحو 560 وحده استيطان في منطقه
القدس المحتله وياتي هذا في اطار مخططات
مستمره لتعزيز البناء الاستيطاني في
المناطق التي احتلتها اسرائيل وضمتها الى
القدس بعد حرب عام
67 نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما دلاله توقيت الاعلان عن هذا
المخطط الاستيطاني الجديد في ظل المساعي
الامريكيه للتوصل لاتفاق اطاري فلسطيني
اسرائيلي وكيف سيؤثر النشاط الاستيطاني
الاسرائيلي المستمر في وضع القدس في
المفاوضات على اتفاق نهائي للسلام
مخطط البناء الاستيطاني الجديد في القدس
المحتله ليس الاول وقد لا يكون الاخير على
ما يبدو فقبل ثلاثه اسابيع اعلنت اسرائيل
عن مناقصات لبناء
1000400 وحده استيطان في الضفه الغربيه
والقدس الشرقيه ياتي هذا النشاط
الاستيطاني المحموم في القدس تحديدا في
وقت تتصاعد فيه وتيره الجدل والتوقعات حول
سعي وزير الخارجيه الامريكي جون كيري
لتحديد مبادئ اتفاق اطاري للمفاوضات
الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه بحلول نهايه ابريل
نيسان المقبل ويتصدر وضع القدس الجدل حول
صياغه هذا
الاتفاق تهويد القدس سياسه اسرائيل فيها
ماضيه اعطيت الموافقه الرسميه لبناء اكثر
من 500 منزل على ارض مدينه يتفاوض
الفلسطينيون حتى تكون عاصمه دولتهم في
المستقبل يشمل المخطط الاخير على وحدات
استيطان في هار حومه على جبل ابو غنيم
جنوب القدس المحتله والنبي يعقوب شمال
المدينه وبيسك زيف تقع المناطق الثلاث في
جزء من الضفه الغربيه الذي ضمته اسرائيل
الى القدس في حرب
67 القرار الاخير سبقه الاعلان قبل ثلاثه
اسابيع عن منقصات لبناء 1400 منزل جديد في
الضفه الغربيه والقدس الشرق
خطوات عاده ما تثير انتقادات الفلسطينيين
بل وحتى الامريكيين الذين يريدون التوصل
الى اتفاق اطار للسلام بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين قبل نهايه العام الجاري بيد
ان تلك الانتقادات لم ولن توقف تلبيب عن
المضي قدما في مشاريعها الاستيطانيه لفرض
امر واقع في حال اي
تسويه تسويه تبدو بعيده في الوقت الراهن
في ظل استمرار خطه الاحزمه ل محاصره مدينه
القدس من جميع الجهات وسد منافذ تواصلها
جغرافيا وديموغرافي مع الضفه الغربيه ضمن
ذلك المخطط ارتفعت نسبه الفلسطينيين
المهجرين من شرقي القدس والضفه الغربيه
الى 5 في خلال العام الماضي فكم مقدسي
سيبقى وكم متر من ارض المدينه لن يصبح
مستوطنه اسرائيليه قبل اي اتفاق تريده
واشنطن باي ثمن وفق صادره دبلوماسيه
امريكيه وضع القدس حتى الان غير واضح في
اتفاق الاطار الذي يسعى جون كيري جاهدا
الى ان يكون جاهزا ومقبولا قريبا رسميا
تقول رام الله انها لن تقبل باي تنازلات
عن ثوابت هي القدس وحق العوده ووقف عمليه
الاستيطان عمليه تستمر لانه على ما يبدو
الضغوط ليست كافيه على اسرائيل ولان العرب
يغرقون في ازمات ما بعد ربيع تحول الى
اعصار سياسي مستمر الى اجل غير
مسمى معنا في هذه الحلقه من الخليل جاد
اسحاق مدير معهد الابحاث التطبيقيه اريج
ومن تل ابيب شمعون اران الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي الاسرائيلي اهلا بضيفنا لو بدانا
بالسيد
اران ان تقدم اسرائيل على هذه الخطوه
الاستيطانيه في عز تحركات جون كري الحاليه
ماذا
يعني
الحقيقه ان هذه النشاطات الاسرائيليه
مستمره منذ امد طويل منذ فتره طويله كانت
عندما كانت هناك دائما مفاوضات كانت هناك
اعمال بناء في المستوطنات
واسرائيل تحافظ على حقها لمواصله البناء
في جميع
انحاء دوله اسرائيل بما في ذلك في اورشليم
القوتس هناك بالفعل انتقادات امريكيه
انتقادات فلسطينيه ولكن لكن المفاوضات
مستمره وهناك تفاهم امريكي لهذه الحقيقه
واسرائيل من جانبها مثلا خطوه بناء واصدار
العطاءات للبناء في شرقي اورشليم القدس
كانت اليوم ايضا في اللجنه المحليه
للتخطيط والبناء اصدار عطاءات للبناء ايضا
في الاحياء العربيه في جابل المكبر في بيت
حنينه في بيت صفافه وفي سور باهر ومصادر
في البلديه اكدت بان القدس من بلديه القدس
ستواصل البناء في جميع انحاء المدينه
لجميع المواطنين يهودا وعربا ولا يجب ان
يعرقل ذلك لان كما نعلم في الماضي ايضا
عندما كان الرئيس الفلسطيني الراحل ياسر
عرفات كانت هناك دائما اعمال بناء
وبالمقابل بموازاه ذلك كانت دائما مفاوضات
بين اسرائيل والفلسطينيين جون كيري اعرب
تحفظاته واشنطن عربت عن تحفظاتها ايه جهات
اوروبيه كبيره ع رب تحفظاتها وكما نعلم
فان ديفيد كاميرون رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
وانجلا ميركل المستشاره الالمانيه ستصل
هذا الشهر لسر وبلا شك سيكون هذا الموضوع
في صلب المحادثات مع القياده الاسرائيليه
نعم انت هنا سيد ران تعبر تقريبا عن موقف
ايديولوجي مبدئي فيما يتعلق بموضوع
الاستيطان من وجهه نظر اسرائيليه ولكن سيد
جاد اسحاق هل ت اعتقد بان فعلا الموقف
الاسرائيلي هو بهذا الاساس الذي يشير اليه
الان السيد
اران اعتقد ان هناك محاوله من الجانب
الاسرائيلي لتحريف الحقائق وما تم الاتفاق
عليه
اي المعروف
ان وزير الخارجيه كيري
عندما ضغط على الجانب الفلسطيني للدخول في
المفاوضه بعد توقف لفتره طويله كان واضح
ان اسرائيل ستقوم
بتقييد لم يكن هناك تجميد ولكن تقييد
لنشاطاتها
الاستيطانيه بينما ما تسعى اسرائيل على
ارض الواقع هو ان تزيد من الوحدات
الاستيطانيه التي تبنى في كافه انحاء الضف
الضفه الغربيه لفرض حقائق على الارض فما
تم الاعلان عليه عنه منذ بدايه 2013 وحتى
الان يتجاوز 12000 وحده استيطان في كافه
انحاء الضفه الغربيه
اي هذه لم تكن موجوده مثل هذا الرقم في
كافه الحكومات الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه وهذه
تبش تشير بشكل واضح الى ان اسرائيل لا
يوجد في القياده الحاليه في اسرائيل شريك
للسلام للجانب الف فلسطيني الذي مد يده
للسلام بينما اسرائيل ترد على العالم وترد
على لجنه المتابعه العربيه واعتقد ان هذه
الخطوه الاسرائيليه يجب ان يكون الرد من
قبل امريك امريكا الراعي لهذه العمليه وفي
رايي المتواضع بان الخطوه الاسرائيليه هي
صفعه في وجه
كيره نعم سيد اران يعني حتى لو تركنا
المواقف الفلسطينيه الغاضبه مثل ما عبر
عنه الان سيد اسحاق ساعطيك ما قالته
السيده تسيبي ليفني وهي وزيره العدل
والمسؤول عن ملف المفاوضات مع الفلسطينيين
تقول اي حجر هذا كلامها اي حجر يتم بنائه
في المستوطنات
المعزوله خارج الكتل الاستيطانيه الكبرى
يمس احتمال التوصل الى تسويه سياسيه تحافظ
على هذه الكتل الاستيطانيه كما انه يصبح
حج جرا في السور الذي يعزل اسرائيل عن
العالم شيئا فشيئا بالطبع السيده ليفني
تتحدث عن المستوطنات المعزوله ولكن هل
ينطبق هذا الكلام ايضا حتى عن هذه
العمليات الاخيره داخل الكتل الاستيطانيه
القائمه نعم يا سيدي ما من شاك بان
هناك تباين داخل الائتلاف الحاكم داخل
الحكومه هناك جهات اكثر تصلب مثل نفتالي
بينت واليوم الوزيره سيبي ليفني المسؤوله
عن ملف المفاوضات وجهت نقدا لاذعا الى
نفتالي بينت ونفتالي بينت كما نعلم يضع
شروطا تعجيزيه للمضيق قدما في المفاوضات
نتنياهو لديه ائتلاف حكومي صعب للغايه من
جهه لديه تيبي ليفني التي تريد التقدم بكل
القوه الى الامام وتوصل الى اتفاق اطار مع
الفلسطينيين ومن الجهه الثانيه هناك جهات
يمنيه
متشدده مثلا الحز حزب البيت اليهودي وجهات
يمنيه اخرى حتى وزير الدفاع مشي عون وجه
نقدا لاذعا الى وزير الدفاء الى وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي كذلك داني دانون نائب
وزير الدفاع وهناك جهات عديده في الائتلاف
الحاكم نتنياهو يشعر بين المتورقه
والسندان عندما يتفاوض مع جون كيري وهناك
فوارق شاسه فيما يتعلق بكل هذه المفاوضات
الجاريه بين الطقمين الاسرائيلي
والفلسطيني رغم كل الخلافات ورغم كل
التبينات الى ان المفاوضات مستمره ولكن لا
يبدو في الافق القريب او البعيد اي احتمال
لانجاز اتفاق
اطار هو فعلا سيد سيد اران يعني بعد اذنك
سيد اران بعد اذنك هي المفاوضات مستمره
ولكن يبدو وكان الحكومه الاسرائيليه تريد
ان تجبر الجانب الفلسطيني على ان يخرج من
المفاوضات غاضبا فترتاح اسرائيل من بعض
الاستحقاقات التي يبدو انها ليست مستعده
لها
الان لا اعتقد لا اعتقد اطلاقا بان
اسرائيل تريد اخراج وابعاد الفلسطينيين من
المفاوضات هناك شروط اسرائيليه لا يقبل
بها الفلسطينيون مثل الاعتراف بيوديه دوله
السرايل السريل مستعده مثلا للاعتراف بكون
دوله فلسطينيه مستقله الى جانب دوله
اسرائيل فلماذا يرفض الرئيس عباس الاعتراف
بيهوديه دوله اسرائيل اسرائيل مستعيد
ليعود اللاجئون الفلسطينييون الى حدود
الدوله الفلسطينيه العتيده كذلك الامر
بالنسبه لغور الاردن اسرائيل مصر على
البقاء في الحدود الشرقيه في غور منطقه
غور الاردن وذلك في اعقاب ما حدث من
انسحاب من جنوب لبنان والانسحاب من قطع
غزه عندما واصلت حماس وتواصل حماس اطلاق
الصواريخ واسرائيل استخلصت العبار وتقول
بان اسرائيل وحدها هي التي ستدافع نفسها س
هنا
هنا الشروط الفلسطينيه نعم اسمح لي انت
هنا تتحدث عن مواصفات التسويه التي تراها
اسرائيل معقوله ولكن انا اردت ان اسال عن
الخطوات المتعلقه بالاستيطان عندما تاخذ
اسرائيل قرارات متعلقه بالاستيطان في
اجواء مساعي سياسيه يقوم بها جون كيري وفي
مساعي وفي اوساط وفي اجواء مفاوضات الا
يبدو قرارا
استفزازيا ليس فقط للفلسطينيين حتى للسيد
جون كيري الذي يقوم بمساعي كبيره
الان بلا شك جون كير يبذل جهودا كبيره
ولكن
اسرائيل ولكن اسرائيل من جانبها يجب ان
تلبي الاحتياجات للسكان مثلا اليوم كما
قلنا القرار باصدار حوالي 560 وحده اعطت
لبناء 560 وحده سكنيه جديده هي ليس فقط
لليهود وانما للعرب ايضا في في احياء
عربيه مختلفه ولكن اسرائيل من جانبها
تواصل هذا الامر هناك تناقض بين المواقف
الاسرائيليه
والميه من الصعب جدا سيد ران من الصعب جدا
من الصعب جدا كما اوضحت التجربه ان يكون
هناك عرب يسكنون في المستوطنات واغلب
المستوطنات التي تمت هي مستوطنات لليهود
ولكن اسمح لي ان اسال سيد جاد اسحاق عما
اذا كان يوافق عن ان عن ان ما اتخذته
اسرائيل هي تقريبا بمثابه خطوه لدفع
الفلسطينيين لمغادره ال المفاوضات
الان
اي لا اعتقد ان هذه الخطوه هي ستدفع
الجانب الفلسطيني الى اي التوقف عن
المفاوضات ولكن من الواضح بان الموقف
الفلسطيني سيكون واضح ان ان توجه اصابع
الاتهام الى الجانب الذي خرب العمليه
التفاوضيه هو الجانب الاسرائيلي ولكن اريد
ان اعقب في في موضوعين الموضوع الاول تحدث
الاخ عن موضوع ان هناك في هذه
العطاءات وحدات سكنيه للعرب يا الاحصائيات
تقول بان الجانب الاسرائيلي في خلال العشر
سنوات الماضيه كان يعطي جميع 300000 مواطن
مقدسي في القدس الشرقيه ما يقارب من
135 وحده سكنيه لترخيص في حين انه كان
يهدم سنويا
125 اذا في المحصله ان هناك عدد كبير من
الفلسط ينيين الذين يبنوا بدون ترخيص بسبب
الاجراءات الاسرائيليه ويقول ان هناك نمو
المستوطنات
الطبيعي يا اخي اذا اخذنا الارقام كل ما
تحتاجه المستوطنات اذا فرضنا ان النمو
الطبيعي هو المشكله لا تحتاج الى اكثر من
2000 وحده سكنيه اذا لماذا تطرح 12000
وحده سكنيه واضح جدا ان اسرائيل تحاول ان
تسبق الزمن وفرض الحقائق على على العرض
لتكون
بمثابه سهم مسلط على الجانب الفلسطيني ل
تقبل الوقائع على الارض في حين ان الحقائق
تقول بان حدود بلديه القدس كما رسمتها كما
ترسمها بلديه القدس لم يعترف فيها اي دوله
في العالم واسرائيل قامت بهذا الاجراء
الاحادي الجانب وهو حسب الشرعيه الدوليه
وحسب الا المتوحده هذا القرار باطل ولاغي
ولا يعترف احد بهذه الحدود المسماه لبلديه
القدس وعلى كل ايضا هناك مساله اخرى تتعلق
بان النشاط الاستيطاني الاسرائيلي الجاري
حاليا سيؤثر بطبيعه الحال على وضع القدس
في اي تسويه سيتم التوصل اليها هذا ما
سنتطرق اليه بعد فاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها دلالات مصادقه
اسرائيل على بناء وحدات استيطان جديده في
القدس المحتله رغم مساعي السلام الامريكيه
الحاليه سيد اران هذا التكثيف للنشاط
الاستيطاني الى جانب الاعتبارات التي اشرت
اليها قبل قليل الا يعني في النهايه ان
التوصل الى تسويه تكون فيها القدس الشرقيه
عاصمه لدوله فلسطينيه مقبله كما تقر بذلك
اغلب دول المجتمع الدولي باتت تقريبا خطوه
مستحيله عمليا على
الارض لا اعرف اذا كانت هذه خطوه مستحيله
ولكن كما نرى فان جميع الامور مطروح على
الطاوله هناك تباين شاسه في مواقف رفين
جون كيري لا ينجح في انجاز اتفاقيه اطار
هناك نيه لتمديد فتره التفاوض حتى نهايه
العام الجاري وذلك في ظل الصعاب الجامه
التي يواجهها جون كيري اسرائيل بالفعل
اعترفت وقبلت بمبدا حل الدولتين لشعبين
ولكن نرى بان هناك تشبث فلسطيني في
المواقف الفلسطينيه وتشبث اسرائيلي في
المواقف
الاسرائيليه ورغم جميع محاولات لجون كيري
وجميع الزيارات المتتاليه الى المنطقه
فانه لا ينجح في راب الصدع وتقريب بين
وجهات النظر الاسرائيليه والفلسطينيه
وهناك احتمالات انجاز هذه الاتفاقيه
اتفاقيه اطار اصبحت ضئيله
للغايه ذكر على ذكر هذا الاتفاق على ذكر
هذا الاتفاق الاطار
سيعم يعني معذره سيده اران على ذكر هذا
الاتفاق الاطاري صحيفه اراد يوم الجمعه
نقلت عن نتنياهو في لقائه مع مسؤولين
اسرائيليين رفيعي المستوى هكذا قالت
الجريده قالت بان نتنياهو قال لهم بان
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وهو شخصيا لن يقبل
باي حال من الاحوال ان يتم ادراج موضوع
القدس الشرقيه في اي اتفاق اطاري يسعى
اليه الان جون كيري هل معنى ذلك ان حتى
الخطوه الاستيطانيه ربما جاءت في الوقت
المناسب لتجهز اي مسعى لوزير الخارجيه لما
امريكي في هذا
الاتجاه لا اعتقد بان هناك نيه لاجهاد
مساعي جون كيري هناك رغبه اسرائيليه
لتحقيق السلام وكون دوله فلسطينيه الى
جانب دوله اسرائيل نتنيا مثلا يتحدث عن
دوله فلسطينيه منزوعه السلاح هناك ما بدات
بتحدث عنه هو الائتلاف الحكومي الصعب
والمواقف المتشدده والمتصل من قبل جهات
يمين مثل البيت اليهودي
وغيرها اذا توصل نتنياهو الى اتفاقيه
وبموجبها ستكون شرقي وشرم القدس جزءا من
من العاصمه الفلسطينيه فلم ما من شك بان
جهات عديده ستنسحب من الائتلاف الحاكم مثل
البيت اليهودي ونتنياهو قد يضطر لادخال
تعديلات حكوميه على حكومته مثلا ربما ضم
حزب العمل برئاسه هيرتسوغ او وحركه شاس
المتدينه ولها مواقف معتدله نسبيا لهذا
الائتلاف الحاكم بمعنى ان لنتنياهو صوبات
جامه فيما يتعلق
بحكومته مثلا خذ على سبيل المثال ان اوري
ارييل وزير البناء والاسكان ومن حزب البيت
اليهودي لديه مواقف متشدده فهو يشجع ويدعم
اعمال البناء في المستوطنات بطبيعه الحال
وهذا ما يؤدي الى اصدار كل هذه الاعطاء
للبناء خاصه في استمرار المفاوضات ولكن
السؤال المطروح لماذا القياده الفلسطينيه
السابقه قبل الرئيس عباس ياسر عرفات كانت
هناك دائما مفاوضات سلام وكانت هناك ايضا
اعمال ارهابيه من قبل طرف الفلسطيني
واسرائيل واصلت اعمال البناء في
المستوطنات وكانت هناك اتفاقيات واي
بلانتيشن وكانت اتفاقيات الخليل وكانت
العديد من الاتفاقات بين سريل وخريطه
الطريق
وير و هذه المشكله سيد اران هذه هي
المشكله ان ان اسرائيل بغض النظر عن
المفاوضات تسير او لا تسير هي مستمره في
هذا الموضوع ولكن الجانب الفلسطيني وهنا
اسال السيد جاد اسحاق الجانب الفلسطيني
ايضا حسب صائب عريقات قال بان الرئيس
محمود عباس بعث برساله الى الرئيس
الامريكي باراك اوباما يقول له فيها ما هي
الاشياء التي لا يمكن التنازل عنها في اي
تسويه يجري الاعداد لها الان من بينها لا
للتنازل عن القدس الشرقيه عاصمه لدوله
فلسطين الى جانب اعتبارات اخرى هل تعتقد
سيد جاد اسحاق بان الجانب الفلسطيني الان
في وضع صعب لانه من ناحيه لا يريد ان
يغادر المفاوضات ومتمسك بالقدس واسرائيل
في نفس الوقت تعمل على ان تجعل هذا الهدف
شبه
مستحيل
يعني بحب اذكر انه عندما قام صدام حسين
باحتلال الكويت لم ياتوا لمفاوضات صدام
حسين على اليه الانسحاب من الكويت وانما
قامت الدنيا ولم تقعد وفرض على صدام حسين
وتم تحرير الكويت وعادت الكويت كدوله
مستقله ما ما ما نسعى ما ما نشاهده
بالنسبه لاسرائيل ان اسرائيل تريد ان تكون
دوله مارقه خارجه عن القانون ت تخالف
الشرعيه الدوليه
ت تضم القدس الى الى اسرائيل وتفرض
الحقائق على
الارض وتستعين
ب الراعي الامريكي لدعمها لعدم اتخاذ اي
اجراءات ضد الشرعيه الدوليه وضد مجلس
الامن اذا هذا علينا ان نفهمه ونحن
كفلسطينيين لا يمكن ان نقبل دوله فلسطينيه
بدون القدس الشرقيه هذا شيء يجب ان يفهموه
واذا
اي لم نستطع تحقيقها في هذه المبادره فان
ان لكل حد حديث
ولنا الاحتلال الاسرائيلي صار له 45 سنه
ولم تحرك ولم يحرك العالم ساكنا امام هذه
المعاناه الفلسطينيه وعلينا ان نبحث عن
بدائل اخرى
وا استراتيجيات اخرى اما هنا هناك قصه سي
تعنا سيد اسحاق بعد
اذنك وزير الخارجيه الامريكي هدد
الاسرائيليين او لمح بشكل ادق بان اسرائيل
تجازف بان تصبح دوله معزوله ومنبوذ مثل ما
حصلت حصل في جنوب افريقيا ان هي تمسكت بكل
هذه المواقف دون دون تغيير هل تعتقد بان
هذه الاشارات ستلعب دور رغم التشدد
الموجود في الساحه الاسرائيليه ورغم ما
يبدو من وضع في صعب لنتنياهو ك كما يقول
مؤيده على
الاقل يعني لا لا نريد ان نقول اننا
بانتظار كرم اسرائيلي لاعطائنا حقوقنا لا
نستطيع ان ننتظر التوازن السياسي في داخل
اسرائيل نحن كفلسطينيين ونحن كعرب وكمس
المين علينا
ان نقدم طروحات مع العالم الغربي ل
لاتخاذ اجراءات تليق بدوله ارقه خارجه عن
القانون دوله تظهر
كافه مظاهر التمييز العنصري وتمارس
البلطجه والارهاب ارهاب الدوله على
الفلسطينيين في كل يوم اعتقد ان المقاطعه
والعزله يجب ان تكون برنامج فلسطيني سلمي
لانهاء هذا الاحتلال الذي مضى عليه اكثر
من 46 عام شكرا جزيلا لك جاد اسحاق مدير
معهد الابحاث التطبيقيه اريش كنت معنا من
بيت اللحم شكرا ايضا لضيفنا الاسرائيلي من
تلبيب شمعون اران محل الشؤون السياسيه في
راديو اسرائيل بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون
قد وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر في امان
[موسيقى]
الله
ه